with five on the shot clock here comes
heroes first hoist yep confidence is a
2-day player has terrific range and also
play Meg John the heat appear to the
youngest player in NBA history to earn
all-nba defense Johnny had a great
summer in summer league in Las Vegas and
Gregg Popovich hoping for bigger things
out of Walker this year actually in the
Bahamas what a wonderful thing to be
able to wrap your arms around a few
whose lives have been disrupted and
displace hard-working great to have her
on our team you can enjoy her work
[Applause]
we rolling those arms and hands there
are children you at nine point to the
strip there of force hero comes nettle
perfect - for a change in your hero
it gives Dylan Ellen
[Applause]
on the 82nd game of last year's regular
season I think was up with the best
Buddhists under-the-radar player
acquisitions that I've seen him a long
time for Miami hero off the shot fake
waiters wide open for three it steps
[Applause]
kendrick none of its 7.0 with a quick
steal in school thrill threes and
they're both seven feet taller or born
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect for shoot locks have made six of
their first eight shots again two-point
lead for Atlanta they're shooting 71%
this first quarter
oh that's pretty toldja hero could
create he dribbled through the day and
set up and with a perfect bounce back
especially for John Crotty a former
Virginia Cavaliers right now there he
goes again
Tyler hero who had 14 points
first quarter stays perfect five minutes
left to the first half hero to the hoop
to the school this man can do everything
is that in your rookie on the offensive
end this seems to pick up this girl too
soon right
four turnovers for trained young and I
hero bring it up for Tyler another
triple Taylor Hero 5 of 7 from downtown
Tyler hero show in Miami his best
performance of this young preseason 23
points just you for it lamb and let the
league with 17 turnovers at game last
season dry itch lefty at three now two
triples in a row for the dragon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the details fire on to the open true
hero
[Music]
young heat back for kendrick gun the
undrafted rookie who played for the
Warriors G League team last year looking
like NBA material for real what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content